guten morgen erst einmal sich fand es
wirklich erschreckend wie auf einmal auf
polizisten losgegangen wird wir auf das
symbol der deutschen demokratie in
ausgegangen worden ist mit dem reichstag
das können wir als deutschland nicht
dulden das können wir am ende nicht
einfach so stehen das sind dann müssen
wir sofort und knallhart durchgreifen
deswegen kann ich diejenigen überhaupt
nicht verstehen die jetzt erklären dass
die polizei dort einen pfefferspray oder
mit schlagstöcken agiert hätte ich halte
das für absolut richtig was die polizei
dort gemacht hätte hat das braucht ein
ganz knallhartes vorgehen gegen
diejenigen die dort mit
reichskriegsflagge mit türkischen
schlagen aber auch beispielsweise haben
wir gesehen anti atomkraft sticker hier
versuchen den reichstag zu stürmen
wir sehen auch gerade noch mal die
bilder von gestern wer trägt dafür die
verantwortung der berliner innensenator
die polizei wer trägt die verantwortung
dafür dass so wenige polizisten so
vielen demonstranten so kurz vor den
türen des reichstags gegenüberstanden
aus meiner sicht sollte schon die
berliner politik mal ihre polizei
durchaus mehr schützen und die polizei
politik überdenken wir haben ja nicht
nur jetzt den fall mit innensenator
geisel sondern wir haben auch schon
andere dinge erlebt die beispielsweise
das landes diskriminierungsgesetz wo man
gesagt hat
man möchte eine beweislastumkehr
einführen und es soll in zukunft der
polizist erklären müssen dass er
niemanden diskriminiert hat und nicht
derjenige diskriminiert worden ist soll
das ganze erneut soll das ganze erklären
müssen das halte ich für absolut ein
fadenscheiniges signal und ich finde das
auch lars klingbeil und konstantin von
notz die eben gerade die aber ihnen
gesprochen haben das auch vielleicht
einmal ihren parteikollegen die sich in
der rot-rot-grünen koalition dort
befinden mit geben sollten ansonsten ist
ziemlich scheinheilig sich jetzt hinter
die polizisten zu stellen
wir sprachen auch über die demonstranten
den mix einem menschen der sich da
zusammengefunden hat was kann die
politik tun um diese menschen
aufzufangen
es ist schon ein absoluter mob und wir
sollten nicht anfangen
mit rechtsradikalen zu bezeichnen die
rechtsradikalen jahren dabei nazis waren
dabei und das verurteile ich auf der
anderen seite haben wir aber eben auch
gesehen dass dort türkische flaggen
gehisst worden sind dass dort menschen
mit anti atomkraft sticker dabei gewesen
sind und deswegen dürfen wir müssen wir
jeden einzelnen brandmarken der unsere
demokratie infrage stellt der
extremistische unterwegs ist und die
anderen die vielleicht einfach auch
manche regeln hinterfragen mit ihnen
müssen wir diskutieren aber wir brauchen
am ende der diskussionsbereitschaft wer
das nicht ist der muss auch sein eigenes
demokratieverständnis hinterfragen was
glauben sie kommen wir jetzt auf ein
neues level können wir mit solcher art
demonstrationen weiterhin rechnen in den
kommenden wochen
wir brauchen eine gesellschaftliche
debatte über die frage wie wir
eigentlich zusammen leben wollen und
hier sehe ich wir haben starke regeln
des demonstrationsrechts der
meinungsfreiheit was gut ist was ein
hohes gut ist in deutschland werden auf
der anderen seite aber eben auch
pressefreiheit und wir haben die bilder
von ihrer kollegin vorgesehen der mann
auf der anderen seite auch
gesundheitsschutz gegenüber jedem
einzelnen von uns wird heute nachmittag
noch meine oma besuchen dies 290 konnte
sie lange nicht besuchen wird zum sehe
aber auch dass zum beispiel die
polizisten ja auch menschen sind die
familie zuhause haben und dass wir sie
am ende eben auch schützen dass das
nicht einfach nur objekte sind auf die
wir zu gehen und auf die man losgehen
kann sondern dass sie eben teilt am ende
menschen sind die wir zu schützen haben
da brauchen wir eine gesellschaftliche
debatte wie weit das demonstrationsrecht
am ende auch gehen darf meiner sicht
immer nur so weit bis es dann am ende
auch die die körperliche unversehrtheit
einzelner einschränkt das ist eine
absolute grenze die dann überschritten
ist und die freiheit auch der polizisten
dürfen wir nicht vernachlässigen
tillmann kuban vielen herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch und ihre zeit
amu